if you're watching this video and it's
loading slowly and you're in the United
States there is a reason why the United
States is now ranked 30th in broadband
speeds and we pay more than many other
westernized nations we've got some info
for you so us download speeds ranked
behind Iceland Romania Bulgaria France
Russia the UK and many more we also pay
more an average of 55 dollars a month
for broadband service while countries
with faster connections like some of the
ones I just mentioned come in at about
$45 a month
Hong Kong which has the fastest internet
speeds in the world they pay about 40%
less than we pay about 31 bucks a month
I guess this shouldn't surprise us
because it seems like most of our stuff
in the United States is not working that
well our infrastructure
now our broadband um is it weird that
we're not talking about this more that
this that because everything's online
the computer it's all online should we
be more concerned about our slow ass
Internet what struck me is what I'm
curious about really after reading that
article was how many of those countries
how much government investment was been
obviously look I get it the government
invested a lot in the Internet to begin
with but to keep those speeds up to date
like is it all the businesses just do it
themselves is that their motivation or
is there is that government work to make
sure because there is a vested interest
for business purposes for every purpose
that the government divert the
government's use appears those guys get
subsidies from the government yeah I
would imagine that they do and we're
leaving it up pretty much two years I
can tell when I'm have all the
information here but we're leaving it up
to Comcast trying to merge with Time
Warner which will have so many customers
it'll there's no incentive for them to
update it and make sure that move into
the top five or top ten because when you
have how many customers they're about to
have 120 million whatever it is if
merger is allowed to go through they'll
control half the countries if high-speed
Internet in the bill we need they're all
paying fifty five dollars a month we
literally we can't we don't know what to
do with all this money right so your
point it's only getting worse the Time
Warner Comcast thing is only gonna make
this worse and what was the one this
week DIRECTV
in AT&T so that even right so it's only
gonna get worse because they have no
interest because there's so little
competition well I think Teddy Roosevelt
taught us that huge monopolies are a
good thing did they help their economy
they helped B or they helped the general
public everybody gets to get a piece of
the pie when one person owns everything
yeah isn't that and by the way we got to
stop calling it broadband is 2014 it's a
woman band it's okay we keep doing sorry
sorry yeah so the the glass merger that
they didn't approve the federal
government was when what was it's not
sprint but what's the other one wanted
to be taken over by anyway they did not
let one of those mergers go by which I
couldn't believe that was because one of
you say here's what if the merger is
doesn't benefit the consumers they're
not supposed to let it happen
they're not supposed to let a merger
happen because it it benefits the
company but not the consumers and that's
what happened so we're gonna get less
choice right when this merger happens
when you get less choice when I get poor
service we're gonna get higher prices
yet they're gonna let this go through
because we live in a banana republic not
technically banana but I like to misuse
that term I mean corrupt you're close
enough what happened to us a number one
are we number one in anything anyway
number one then but right now I mean we
said but we said we are number one in
bankruptcies attributed to medical care
we're number one I think any dust rise
world and infant mortality so we we've
got a lot of number ones so we've got a
couple just switching number one ago
that's number one index we a lot of
those number one but back in the day and
those things were were there any that
really I guess at one point we must have
had the number one sugar growing
economies or that someone grow economy
in the world and you know were were
number one in war uh you know you say
about the Washington Senators before
they left town you know uh the
Washington was first in war first in
peace last in the American League yeah
and uh uh but now we're not even not
even first in peace no one no one would
know would no one would read argue that
with a straight face
III worried about like that that
something like the internet the way that
that again I just feels like that the
this us maintaining
Elite internet speeds and status like
that requires government intervention
somehow I'm not saying they have to pay
dough but then they have to subsidize
that they have to spur well they would
have to tell Comcast hey you have to up
if we're gonna allow this merger here's
the deal by 2022 were 6th in the world
make that happen
whatever it is get the speed up to
whatever it needs to be yeah
does the government in a weird way have
a vested interest in our Internet not
being that good no III that we can't
have we won't have access to information
as easily well I think benefit so what
what I think should be happening is that
the municipality should be making
internet available to everyone for free
right because they done studies and they
figured out that the places that do that
it actually helps everyone's business if
you're able to access Wi-Fi no matter
where you are inside of a city if the
business goes up productivity goes up
tax revenue goes up so it pays for
itself it's one of those things that
helps people get kids get educated kids
can get on the internet whatever they
want at school at home on the bus no
matter what so this is it so they can
have Wi-Fi so that's what we of course
that's what we should be doing just like
health care universal health care we
should have universal Wi-Fi and Internet
access
because that helps everybody it rises
everyone but of course we won't because
there's money and a select few people
and keeping it the way it is
so speaking of those select few people
so we've done every week we've been
doing stories on net neutrality so net
neutrality got flipped it was by an FCC
appointed guy that was an Obama campaign
bundler who also worked in the telecom
lobby is as a telecom lobbyist so
between this story and net neutrality is
the Internet as we know it really on
shaky ground right now like are we in
our last hour Mike receives on shaky
ground right now this we don't we don't
really live in an in a bakra see that's
where our leaders are responsive to the
there are people that they are voting
for them the voters their only
responsible to the donor class we say it
all the time and you know what happens
when you look at the gun control right
we talk about it all 90% of the people
wanted background checks we didn't get
it what do you call that what kind of
government do we have this isn't a
democracy anymore this is government by
the few for the few and of the few bring
us home all that was pretty effective uh
bringing us home I don't think you know
with
let's let's roll let's bring it let's
take a nice broad finish and make it
much narrower because that's what we
like to do television sorry uh you know
the net neutrality debate is not over
that's the good news is important to
keep talking about I'm not saying that
we should be dismissed but the the FCC
commissioners seem open to act uh were
in the public debate period to hearing
about it to sort of hearing and so I
don't know I'm pointlessly I'm always a
little optimistic and I think that's
ridiculous but it's not okay that's not
with you it's not signed and sealed yet
and part of it is that we talk about it
and say that that it needs to be
preserved